and i just want to be friends good
plus a little extra also i love you
my perfect valentine's day i'm at home
three cell phones in front of me
fielding desperate calls from people who
want to buy one of the 50 restaurant
reservations i made over six
months ago
what's this what is this i don't know
it's on your desk
but who put it here and for what purpose
is there when i sat down
happy valentine's day
it's me i'm the bobble head
yes ah
hello angela did you hear somebody
totally rocked the house and got me the
best present i've ever gotten
really i wouldn't know anything about
that but i'm glad you enjoyed it oh i
did
i did i didn't get anything for
valentine's day oh i bet you will before
the day is over
really well i hope i do
pam hi how you doing good listen uh may
i speak with you
privately you can't fire me dwight just
cause michael's not here no
pam just i'm just
wait you need to get something for your
girlfriend yes and the reason i didn't
get anything for this particular person
who shall remain nameless is that she's
not really the kind of person you think
would be into valentine's day
she's kind of tightly wound
exactly okay well
sometimes the gift is really about the
gesture you know like
what it means instead of what it is you
mean
like a ham no
not like a ham it's about doing
something
so that the person knows that you really
care about her okay i get it that's
great okay shut up i know exactly what
to do
women are like wolves if you want a wolf
you have to trap it you have to snare it
and then you have to tame it keep it
happy care for it
feed it lovingly the way an animal
deserves to be loved
and my animal deserves a lot of loving
what is my perfect crime i break into
tiffany's at midnight
do i go for the vault no i go for the
chandelier it's priceless
as i'm taking it down a woman catches me
she tells me to stop
it's her father's business she's tiffany
i say no
we make love all night in the morning
the cops come and i escape in one of
their uniforms
i tell her to meet me in mexico but i go
to canada i don't trust her
besides i like the cold 30 years later i
get a postcard
i have a son and he's the chief of
police this is where the story gets
interesting
i tell tiffany to meet me in paris by
the trocadero
she's been waiting for me all these
years she's never taken another lover
i don't care i don't show up i go to
berlin that's where i stash the
chandelier
here's another place
it's beautiful hello
so why don't we try this out
to see what would happen give it a
little test drive what do you say
you pretend to be angela's father you
will play angela and uh
i will pretend to be you that way you
can see what it looks like when you're
up here
[Music]
hello i'm angela martin and i work with
he doesn't understand a word you're
saying although born just minutes from
here he speaks only german
closed society so now after the readings
by all of your sisters we will arrive at
the vows so
conrad
he's explaining um why we're here what
we're doing here making introductions
then he's going to have andy repeat a
bunch of stuff he's going to ask andy to
produce a ring
um i have um now just uh
some twine for our purposes and you will
put
a ring on her finger
yeah then he's going to ask andy uh if
you would like to marry angela
and you will reply i do
and he's going to ask angela if she
would like to marry andy
to which you will reply i do
what do we got i was thinking of
proposing to esther today
wow okay congratulations that's a really
big step she's got a ton of great
qualities she's young she's beautiful
jeans
so pure you could lick them her family
admires me
my family tolerates hers a lot of them
are the same people because we're third
cousins which is great for bloodlines
and isn't technically incest right in
the sweet spot i think you're gonna be
really happy
plus her dowry contains a walk-in
freezer full of frozen
premium cattle sperm that's a lot of
pros and did i mention that she weaves
colorful durable blankets and rugs it
all adds up
so what is the problem
i love you and i don't care that
philip's not my son
i will raise a hundred children with a
hundred of your lovers if it means i can
be with you
can you put that down this expresses how
loudly i love you it's too loud
this is a ring taken from the buttocks
of my grandmother
put there by the gangster patriarch of
the coors dynasty
melted in a foundry run by mennonites
okay
yes yes i will
i love you i love you
and i lied to you what philip's your son
what why would you say that i just
needed you to want to marry me
because you wanted to marry me
get out i'm a dad you're a dog
hello angela hi dwight you look as
beautiful as the queen of england
thank you don't linger break left
left
the schrutes have their own traditions
we usually marry standing in our own
graves
it makes the funerals very romantic but
the weddings are a
bleak affair
as is traditional to the shoots the
lovers
are standing in their own graves as a
reminder
that this is the only escape from what
they are about to do
you see i get what they're trying to do
but why the graves so shallow
arise my love my fair one
and come away for lo the winter is past
the rain
is over and gone the time
of singing has come and the voice
of the turtle dove is heard in our land
let me see your face let me hear your
voice
for your voice is sweet and your face
is calmly i now pronounce you
man unvive
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you